hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at vertex
arrays definitely make sure that you
check out that video if you haven't
already and our kind of application was
almost up to the stage where we didn't
actually need to call any kind of raw
OpenGL calls in order to render our
little rectangle and triangle onto the
screen which is pretty exciting however
the last thing that remained was
probably the most critical part of the
whole thing and that is the actual draw
hole now what does a draw pole well to
put it simply it's just a call to
actually draw something onto the screen
right
it's our command where we actually tell
the graphics card I've given you a bunch
of information you know bound a shader
I've told you how to do things I need
you to actually go ahead and run that
vertex shader with this kind of geometry
bound and actually run this pixel shader
this fragment shader to work out the
colors of every pixel on the screen I
want you to actually do that it's the
actual draw command right that is called
a draw call now in this case our Drupal
is GL draw elements right there's a
bunch of different ways to actually
dispatch draw commands but we're using
geo draw elements and that's the actual
piece of opengl code that is still
inside our actual application now we
want to get rid of that but to do that
like properly and not just like hack it
in we need some sort of renderer right
and in fact today what we're gonna do is
we're gonna talk about this entire kind
of rendering architecture and I really
want to actually discuss this properly
with diagrams not gonna do that today
because I'm just gonna show you guys the
practical implementation of everything
be far too long but yeah video will
probably be at about about an hour long
if I was to actually discuss both the
theoretical kind of how this is gonna
work and draw diagrams and then also
kind of write all the code for so
there's gonna be the code part of it
if you guys are interested in the actual
kind of renderer specifically renderer
to render API to run a command that kind
of architecture in hazel drop a comment
below I'll probably make a dedicated
video just talking about that probably
like a midweek thing I'm not gonna like
just you know take over the main episode
just to kind of explain this I want to
maybe pick a midweek thing there's an
extra video really that will kind of
supplement this so let me know if that's
something that you're interested in
before we continue just want to thank
all the patrons that make this series
possible patreon for / de jure no huge
thank you all those people because the
sir just wouldn't be here without you
guys if you go ahead and support the
series
you'll get a lot of kind of perks such
as getting videos early like a week
earlier usually so when a new episode
comes out like live on YouTube you can
already see the next one straight away
on patreon so it's like just you're just
week ahead of everyone else and then you
also get access to the private
development repository which I already
have like a full renderer and a bunch of
other cool things like I think I'm this
week I've added like animation to this
look so that we have like animated
meshes and I've added like a material
system it's pretty exciting and it's
kind of I'm just working on that
basically just as like a little hobby
project I guess just as fast as I can I
mean all that stuff and there's even
like a road map like that's like I've
set up like a github project on that
private github repository look like a
github project was like tasks and
currently working on it's kind of like a
real software developing team so it's
really cool definitely check that out
and help support the series because
that's how we can have these videos for
free which is amazing okay we're going
to dive into this as I said not gonna
talk too much about the architecture
you'll kind of see it through the code I
think so rather than me kinda explaining
to you how it works and taking a long
time to do that I want to just really
get in and start actually writing code
before I do that I will give you some
theoretical knowledge though because I'm
trying to teach you guys how to show you
know abstract code in front of you so
basically what we need is a renderer so
what does a renderer do right let's
think about rendering a triangle what do
we actually need to do to render a
triangle right and don't just think of
this as a triangle think of it as some
piece of geometry all right so let's
just let's just make the world 3d for a
second in our minds and think about a
cube you want to render a cube in your
3d world what do you actually need well
there's a few components that I can
think of right to actually render
something we know that we need a vertex
array which is something that contains
the vertex buffer and the UNIX buffer
right references to those two we need a
shader otherwise we have no idea how to
do stuff and I think that's a minimum
that's pretty much it right I mean we
need to like clear the screen every
frame but that's kind of just details
that we don't really care about now a
cube in a 3d world well where are we in
relation to the cube right how are we
looking at the cube that's a camera
system right so we need a camera well as
a camera a camera is just a projection
matrix and a view matrix right those two
pieces of information we absolutely need
in a form of a camera we also need the
actual position
of the cube in world space right so
whether you know 3d world is the cube
actually located what's the how is it
rotated you know how does it sit we need
the whole transformation matrix of the
cube that's really important if we're
talking about more advanced details of a
more complete render rather we will
eventually have here we also need to
know what surface material the cube has
so what's the cube made out of is it
wooden is it plastic
how reflective is it how's a textured
all of that kind of stuff we need to
know the material of the actual cube we
also need to know information about the
environment right so we need to know
what lights are in the environment is
there sunlight is there a huge like
directional light coming from somewhere
because we're outside and that's our
sunlight you know what does the world
look like do we have like an environment
map some kind of like radiance map that
basically just describes the environment
around us because that's really
important for things like image based
lighting which we'll be using in the
future right we need all of that
information and hopefully the way that I
the way that I've kind of described to
you it starts to separate into two
different things
stuff that's concerned with the
environment and stuff that's concerned
with the actual like object that we're
rendering right those are the two kind
of important things
so again environment what is that that's
our lighting environments of water
where are our lights you know is there a
bunch of point lights is there like a
big directional light that stuff right
as well as the cube map that is our
environment that we need for any kind of
reflections right to do with that and we
need that for rendering like physically
based materials right those two things
and then our camera where are we looking
in right that kind of stuff is based on
the environment and you can really start
to differentiate it that way because if
you think about it what if I want to
render two cubes right I want to run to
I want to render a whole scene of
objects well what do I need for that do
I need two for each object like update
the environment map or the light setup
or the camera norm I'm looking at the
scene from one camera all the objects
gonna be rendered with that same set of
parameters that's how you know what
belongs to the actual scene that is what
we need to do when we tell our Enduro we
want to begin a scene so we'll have a
command that's like
renderer begin scene right begin scene
means all that information it means know
about the environment it needs to know
about the camera right that stuff needs
to be setup and the environment includes
the lights in this case then we have the
object per object kind of basis right so
I'm gonna render three cubes or I don't
know maybe I've got a level and I've got
like walls and I've got like characters
all that stuff right the things that are
primarily need for that are materials so
what material is that actual object
using right how do i render it with what
material and then the second thing is
cause the second thing the
transformation of the object right so
where in the world is it right those are
the two important things that we
actually need and based on everything
I've described here you can render a 3d
scene like no problem at all right done
right you need that kind of stuff to
actually make that happen so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna focus we we
don't having if this yet is a little
conceptual right we don't actually have
a camera system we don't actually have a
material system we don't actually have
lighting or environments right we will
in the future definitely but we don't
right now but we're gonna still lay the
foundation for all that kind of stuff
and it's important to understand the big
picture because I don't want to sit here
and give you some kind of like really
entry-level basic beginners tutorial
that's just like oh you know we're gonna
render triangle this way no I'm looking
at the big picture I've written game
enters before I've worked on triple-a
game engines before right I know how
they work and this is me kind of taking
a look at the whole holistic view of
things and laying this kind of
groundwork so that you understand that a
renderer is a bit more complicated than
just like hey let's submit this thing
but on the other hand I'm trying to make
it simple enough so that I can squeeze
this whole thing into like an episode
and also not confuse you guys too much
and actually see results on the screen
pretty quickly and the object stuff we
don't particularly have either like
transformation matrices and I'm really
talked about them yet we will in the
future but it's just important to
understand that distinction between
what's part of the renderer and what's
part of the actual object thing okay
so we're gonna go ahead and and do right
now is actually write that kind of
render and begin sane and sane so the
weight is in the flow is we basically
say a renderer I'm beginning a scene
that's where we supply all the renderer
stuff so the camera the environment then
we render all of our meshes each mesh
that we render is going to be at a
different
transform usually so we'll take in some
kind of trance like transformation
matrix so that eventually obviously
that'll make its way to like to the
shader and that's how we actually
transform something right that's where
all of our mattress go and then finally
we have an end scene all right they're
just kind of same signals of this scene
is over right and then usually what
happens is all of that stuff doesn't get
rendered immediately it just gets
submitted into a render like command
queue essentially so we try to render
command out of it and we submit that
right and we kind of just take our time
to submit the whole scene I'm gonna be
explaining everything in this episode
anyway but I would love to do it more
in-depth anyway in a dedicated video but
the point is we take all this time to
submit everything to a render kind of
command queue right which again could be
later evaluated on a separate render
thread right that's what a
multi-threaded game engine actually does
and that is actually what we're going to
do in the future
right but we're gonna create this kind
of command queue right of commands that
our renderer has to fulfill we take our
time and submit all of that and then
when the whole scene has been submitted
and we actually ignore what makes up the
whole scene only then do we render it
why because guess what when you have the
full big picture of your scene you can
really heavily optimize it you can just
just call things that are outside of the
view frustum you can decide which
materials which objects have the same
material so that you can batch them
together you can do really cool car
optimizations sorting all of that kind
of stuff that needs to actually be done
you can only do once you have the whole
scene so you can't just go ahead and
immediate mode just render everything as
soon as it comes in that's what we're
gonna do today because I stymie the
quickest way to do this but very soon
we're gonna restructure this thing and
we're gonna kind of build this renderer
so it actually works like a real
renderer that's gonna be super exciting
anyway enough talking let's jump in and
create this whole renderer thing I'm
gonna show you how it interacts with
opengl because obviously we need to
actually dispatch that drill call and
that drop all is GL draw elements which
of course is OpenGL specific in DirectX
you know would be like calling the
context or the drive or whatever they
mean like draw indexed and then that
would be doing a sign thing that's the
equivalent draw elements interact X but
here we're just dealing with four
elements let's go ahead and create this
whole renderer thing and yeah I mean
this is the beginning of something big
so that's really cool let's go ahead
jump into the code okay so this is what
we heard last time it's important that
we have this because this is our
reference it should look exactly the
same right so what we need to do now is
go into application and just think about
the API that's what I like to do first
of all right so we have this clear color
and we set it and then we clear our
buffer which is great we bind this kind
of stuff and then we have our actual
draw call now what I'm going to do is at
the beginning what we're really gonna do
is call ran draw begin same as I said
right and this is going to actually like
dispatch light it's gonna start that
same that's going to contain all of the
information about the scene right so
essentially what we're dealing with here
is a camera you know lights and then
environment and you could probably argue
that environment is actually or lights
are actually part of the actual
environment right but that's essentially
what a scene needs to have and in the
future we might just have a struct that
is essentially like house scene settings
or our scene setup or whatever you want
to call it right but for now we don't
have any of this there I think maybe in
the next episode or so we're gonna
probably talk about cameras because
that's gonna be one of the most
important things and there's also no way
that we can begin a 3d scene building a
3d scene without actually having a
camera setup that we can control with
like the mouse so that's gonna happen
soon we'll have an end scene right which
signals that this scene is kind of
that's it that's the end we're done
submitting to this scene right and then
in the middle is where we kind of submit
our geometry all right so we could have
something that's called submit write and
then we can maybe just submit a mess you
can call this function submit mesh and
of course submit geo or submit geometry
all right you can call whatever you want
I'm just gonna leave it really simple
and just call it as submit the reason I
can just leave it as submit is because I
mean obviously we're dealing with C++ we
have overloaded functions so based on
the type that we actually submit we
should be able to easily discern if this
is like a mesh or if it's in this case
we're just gonna submit a role vertex
array but that's kind of how that works
right and then usually what will happen
of course is this kind of shade of stuff
that's associated with this right that
will be inside a material and the
material will be like a mesh will have a
material right we don't have meshes yet
either
but when we do they'll have materials
right so we kind of submit this that's
kind of these shaders inside the mesh
that's inside it's inside the material
that's inside the mesh right
that's how we kind of get access to it
in a more complete kind of renderer okay
and then finally usually what we do is
at some point we flush the renderer now
usually this is done on a separate
thread if you're talking about a
multi-threaded game engine design but
you know for now obviously where we
don't know any of that and we don't even
have a real render command queue and
we'll talk about that later because
again we need to submit everything into
basically a buffer that can then be
executed on a different thread so we'll
talk about that later that's going to be
a huge thing that we do in the future as
well okay cool so that's it so obviously
the thing that I want to submit is my
square VA and I still need to bind my
shader right now because that's not
actually done yet so what I do is I
begin my sin
I buy my shader and then I render my
vertex array and I'm going to do the
same thing for this so I'm going to bind
this second shader right and then I'm
going to render this second vertex array
so I'll copy this submit call and this
time I'll submit this vertex array and
that should be it now in terms of this
kind of stuff this clear color this is
going to live somewhere else so the
renderer is the high level class right a
renderer is an actual like it's a it's a
full-on renderer right it doesn't deal
with things like aw let's clear the
screen that's beneath it right it deals
with things like scenes and meshes and
high-level conscious constructs so what
we need to do for here is actually well
it depends how you want to wear this
stuff obviously terminology is different
I like calling it render commands
surrender command clear right and then
to the clear color will do render
command you know set clear color for
example right again you could construct
this however you like right so what you
could actually do is say that I want to
clear with a specific color and then
just pump that in here we're just gonna
set the clear color like that sending
the clear color is not something that's
done that often anyway usually you're
not you care what color you clear too
because you'll be rendering everything
on top of the clear color you should
never really see the clear color in fact
I'd probably argue that a good clear
color would be like magenta or something
really offensive so that you know that
oh my gosh like I'm rendering past my
geometry into the clear color that
should never happen cuz you should
always have like some kind of skybox or
environment map
way if you have a big threes in all
right that's here right this replaces
all of the card that we have here right
so now let's talk about implementing it
so we already have a renderer and we
have a render API but this is gonna get
slightly restructured well actually
create a renderer API class now this you
could call this render API it's there's
a huge like school authority I mean it
could be like renderer API or render api
usually I looked a lot of people call it
render API just cuz easier but I like to
actually call a renderer API because
it's not like what what is Rande API
right this is the API for the renderer
it's a bit of a different thing so I
like to be a bit more specific I guess
and deliver it with my naming so
renderer API is going to be a class that
is going to be again implemented
depending it's gonna be an interface
it's gonna be it's gonna have an
implementation per platform right per
actual like physical like rendering API
right so we'll have one for OpenGL one
for DirectX now what we actually need to
have in here is the actual API right so
the actual API type we're currently
storing inside and I know where that
renderer file disappear to let's move it
here this kind of stuff right so we need
to have this enum class I'm just gonna
call this API and this is gonna be what
API weezing so none or OpenGL at this
right right I'll make another little
public divider here just because I like
to have types at the top then all the
public functions then like all the you
know private like methods and then after
that the private members but anyway we
have this API type up here this is again
gonna be something that's going to be in
just an interface right so virtual void
clear write equals zero right and again
we could deal with like Const and non
cons I don't think that's necessary
doesn't really matter this is never
gonna have Const or anything it's a
renderer API it's just a series of
commands it doesn't really matter
especially with OpenGL because it
doesn't have state so I'm not gonna
bother kind of decorating names but that
stuff just for now at all virtual void
set clear color we have a nice map
library when might as well use it so
I'll include GLM
and I'm going to just use Const GL
that for because we'll probably end up
defining colors like that
in the future anyway so that's gonna be
them and then finally we need our actual
draw call so virtual void draw indexed
I'm gonna call it the same way so our
text calls it because elements I don't
know draw elements is great but we're
again we're calling it an index buffer
so we might as well call this draw
indexed and again for now this is gonna
take in a concert pointer definite not
that there's going to be our vertex
array all right and we're taking this by
reference just because we don't need to
increment the ref count at this rate
like at all really clear text all right
because well actually taking ownership
we're just reading it we could make this
like a weak point or if you really want
it to bit and that's just needless we'll
just leave it as that and then we'll
just include vertex array okay and
that's gonna obviously be equals zero as
well okay so that's our kind of renderer
API now what we actually need is this
stuff so we need to have a private
static API s API alright this is gonna
be our static well what API is actually
active at the moment and then we're
gonna have an inline API get API right
and this is going to return as API and
that's going to be static of course so
we'll have to make a CVP file so we can
contain this API definition so we'll
call this renderer API dot CPP to
include our PC H will include the actual
render render API
don't H namespace hazel
and then I'm just copy that
April grinder API API OpenGL cuz that's
the one we're using and then we'll just
stick this namespace everywhere okay
cool so that's it that's actually all we
need here um that's the render API
that's selected obviously we need to
have an actual API right but that's
gonna be something that's actually gonna
be stored in our renderer when it wants
to dispatch commands to the renderer API
specifically there's probably gonna be
inside the render command class that we
actually need now I'm not sure if we
should create this in the same class as
the renderer I was saying no just
because it's gonna get pretty big so
what I'll do is I'll create a header
file that's going to be render command
dot H right and render command dot H is
going to be our actual war render
commands so render commands are going to
call into this API and actually in let's
delete this for one and also this um we
can still have get API by the way I'll
just include I think we render command
which will include render API we'll
still have these commands right sorry
we'll still have this get API function
just as useful to us the renderer or
what API it's using but this will be a
bit different
it'll be a render API API yep and then
get API will just return this render API
that we have here oh this is different
isn't it this kind of becomes the same
in a way because the renderer will have
access to actual render commands so it
it'll just end up being around your API
get API like that right and this of
course will not get stored so we'll
still have that dead just because we
still need to be aware of the API and
then we'll have to go into all of our
ideas and actually fix that should be
pretty easy really all we're doing is
just adding that so if I copy that and
paste it everywhere and I think we also
need to do it for our vertex array okay
done and that's the only change we have
to make just to write back to that ok
cool so back in the renderer
we're gonna have all of our actual
functions right and I'll set these up
before I set up the Rena commander so
that you kind of know how it works I
guess
so static void begin sane and again to
do right will take in all of our kind of
like same parameters that we need but
for now we'll have nothing collapse
static void and seen all right I'll put
them close together and then we need our
actual like submission right and again
after we have submission we'll probably
have and I'll take an income share
pointer it's a vertex alright just like
in the render API in this again that's
right okay that's pretty straightforward
in this case what you could do is just
immediately dispatch it to the actual
render command do you actually have but
and you know I mean I'm not gonna do
that because this has to be a proper
implementation for the future right but
if we look at what this function is
gonna do and what I'll do actually is
I'll make sure we've got a CVP file I'll
delete this old code I'll just use a
visual assist here to just create all of
the implementations for our functions
done begins sins gonna do nothing for
now and since them do nothing in the
future as I said you know begin sin
takes all of our same parameters what
does it need to do it needs to make sure
that the shaders that were using
basically get the right uniforms and
those uniforms are gonna be things like
which environment map we're using so
which cube Maps sample from it's gonna
be like the camera kind of details like
the projection matrix and the view
matrix where the camera isn't well
spaced any calculations we might need
for lighting and stuff like that right
so that stuff is going to be set up and
begin scene and eventually probably
stored in the current scene so that when
you render something it can submit that
kind of stuff into the shape it can
upload that data as shader uniforms
right come so that's what it's gonna do
in the future right now it does nothing
because we don't have any time submit is
the only thing that we do and what does
it do in this case really simple it just
says render command
well again it's what it's actually gonna
do right is it's gonna submit it into a
queue right intellectus render command Q
and
eventually that render command kitten
get evaluated probably in a different
thread and it will get rented right but
for now again we're doing this really
he's the easy way right we're just
saying render command draw indexed right
and it's just going to take you in that
vertex array okay so render command draw
index doesn't exist because the render
command class doesn't even exist yet but
it's going to now render command this is
where it's interesting what's going to
happen in render command is it's going
to have a renderer API pointer right s
API renderer API up or right and this
friend of commands gonna be real simple
right this is gonna be this is almost
like a static wrapper for the actual
implementation so in this case what
render commands gonna do is again we
have a command called draw indexed which
takes in a Const shared pointer of
vertex array all right so to put that in
here we can even make it in line because
it's a real simple function and it's
just gonna say s renderer API draw
indexed and in this case vertex array
that's basically what it is right
is this a little in line again it's in
line so it shouldn't be an extra
function call or anything like that
right and even if we didn't mark it in
line up and show the compiler would if
you compile and all this mud with
optimizations with sufficient
optimizations turned on right and then
that just lets us write code such as
that which is really like cool right and
just make sure that we obviously make
this a static void and this has to be
static and we actually have to move to
implement this so we'll create a render
command dot CPP file which will include
our PCH of course and our around the
command header and then we're just going
to set this to be no and we have to
create the opengl one in a minute of
course because that's gonna be rational
code but this is going to be new OpenGL
renderer API right and this will of
course include that which is going to be
in hazel slash platform
and I actually can't remember if
platform is inside hazel I never can
it's not okay so it's gonna be an
include flat yeah it shouldn't be
because it's not by the API platform
OpenGL and OpenGL renderer API that's
where our roll kind of OpenGL calls are
really going to go so right now it's
like platform OpenGL I'm going to make
that file so I'm gonna right click here
go to item we're gonna have a header
file it's gonna be called OpenGL
renderer API and then we're also gonna
make a CPP file that's going to be I'll
save a file we'll put out PCH we're
creating so many files but you guys kind
of get the idea I play this isn't too
annoying will include you know renderer
slash sorry hazel / render up slash
renderer API dot H right name space
hazel and then we'll have our class
OpenGL renderer API which will be a
renderer API right and then this is
gonna be really simple we're just gonna
grab all this stuff and implement it
right easy so we'll get rid of the
equals zero and add an override instead
and again I'm just gonna get let's just
put a namespace cable into the CPP file
I'm gonna get visual assist to generate
this stuff for us nice and simple okay
cool so I guess what this stuff is gonna
do it's actually gonna do our it's
actually gonna run our code so we need
to include glad all right set clear
colors gonna call GL clear color right
with color ah color dot G color dot B
colored or a
right it's the same as X Y Z W right GLM
just gives us multiple kind of aliases
for the same variables that we can
access which is nice gel clear we'll
just do gel clear again this stuff is
you know quite temporary because a lot
of times you don't want to clear both
the color and the buffer and you don't
want to clear but the color behind the
depth buffer but for now again really
simple really really primitive in the
future we'll probably take in flags as
to what you actually want to do what you
actually want to clear and also this
clear command is probably something that
frame buffers will actually end up
calling not just like inside our loop
like that try indexed is gonna do our GL
draw elements again for now which is
drawing triangles because we have no
idea what kind of primitive like like
type we actually want to draw them at
the moment is just triangles for now
count is gonna be vertex array don't get
but get index buffer
all right index buffer get count GL
again we've only got one type of index
buffer right now and that's the unsigned
int unsigned int and then the point of
the venus is going to be Nam okay so
there we go that's how drop call done
okay and now inside obviously from our
actual like interface right
sorry not from our interface from render
command I'm getting a little bit lost
here because this stuff is there's tons
of this stuff and it's not even showing
up with my searches which is fantastic
but inside render command you can see
that because the API at the moment is
set to be OpenGL renderer API and not
sure why didn't this stuff he's not
working render API inside sorry it's
just inside run a command obviously so
once because it set to OpenGL renderer
API right when we actually called raw
indexed from a render command it's gonna
dispatch it to that and that's just
gonna work right obviously in the future
this kind of stuff will be set
dynamically not just equals new OpenGL
renderer API when we start up our
application and we create the right
context it's going to actually specify
which render API it's using by creating
like a new OpenGL renderer API
okay cool and you obviously don't worry
about like memory leaks or anything like
that this is a pointer that's gonna last
the entire lifetime of our whole
application and also it's a pointer to a
class with no members so it's a one byte
memory leak if it is a memory leak right
and I guess it's just one part of memory
that we're never gonna clear up until
the end of our application because it
never needs to be cleared up so please
don't worry about that okay cool um I
think this is almost done I don't even
remember the code that I've typed so if
we go to render at LCVP yeah I mean draw
indexed right we dispatched that and I
think that should be pretty good to be
honest so if we go back into application
what I should be able to do is just call
inkless just include the actual render
what is it hazel
renderer renderer H right if that's not
already included which it totally might
be anyway will include that and then
instead of doing all of this you know we
should set out play call I guess we can
set it to the same thing that we had
advised before I'm here we were just
clearing the color buffer bit now we're
clearing both color and depth which is
good so we'll pop that in there so
apparently doesn't have does rendering
clear and the command because if it does
then he it does so we should have access
to that our render command doesn't have
that our renderer API does yep of course
we need to actually make those functions
so this set clear color and everything
that we have here will copy this well
paste it here and we'll kind of change
it a bit so this becomes inline static
instead of vessel right and then
obviously the implementation of this is
just going to be dispatching it to the
renderer API so render API clear and
this becomes render API set clear color
color okay and then back here that
should now work
so we have our clear color we'll just
put curly brackets around this to create
a vector for and then in yeah I mean
instead of waiting we're near any of
this
anymore so we've just got kind of we
beat you now seen but she could even if
you want to you know you could even put
this into a scope just so that you're
kind of clear as to when you kind of
begin and when you and maybe something
like that not going to bother with that
but some people do that just in case it
helps you you can do that if you want
we have begin team we have n scene and
then we actually draw a scene right so
we bind the shader we submit the vertex
array which should bind it oh that's one
thing I didn't do I didn't buy my vertex
array so the renderer right when it
submits this and says let's draw indexed
what a shoot drew is actually bind the
vertex array obviously and then actually
issue the draw command this is a drop
this is a render command render commands
do not do multiple things right unless
they're like maybe specifically supposed
to write render commands do not do
multiple things what that means is that
you do not like for example be like that
x-ray bind here nor this is a this just
draw index does it all it doesn't draw
indexes find anything doesn't do
anything it's a plain old vanilla render
command so the renderer is in charge of
abstraction such as being like bind the
vertex right mind the shadow sell the
materials do all the sorting that kind
of stuff right because much higher level
and that's what it operates on okay I'll
say to that work let's hit f5 and see
what happens I really need to make some
t-shirts with that alright coming soon
okay and once that quick compose you can
see we get the exact same result which
is pretty awesome okay so that's that
right theoretically what we can do
hopefully is actually just get rid of
glad here so when up and include cloud
anymore we're not including in the
header file either right if I hit ctrl
f7 to compile this code it works right
beautiful so we don't need glad anymore
we're just completely using hazel
Hazel's are an API to actually render
this stuff which is pretty cool for
homework what you guys could do is
remove this code from the application
classes inside hazel and move it into
sandbox because we should really start
doing that and I'll probably do that in
the next episode but that'll be a nice
little exercise you'll have to remove
all this vertex right stuff and
hopefully like the you know it works
cross module and it links properly it
should everything should be great and
that's that that's pretty cool we have
the beginnings of our renderer yeah
enjoy this video if he didn't hit the
like button as I said in the beginning
of the video you can help support this
series by going out a patron I come for
slash the Turner huge thank you as
always to all the people that make this
series possible next time we're gonna
talk about cameras because know this is
all great that we can render a bunch of
objects on the screen but there's two
things that's missing from this right as
I said we can we don't know where we're
rendering where we're rendering the
objects we're not supplying any kind of
transformation matrix we need to do that
and then the other thing is we need to
actually supply a camera so that we can
move the camera around and do all of
that kind of fun stuff so we're gonna
talk about cameras next time and then
after that I'm not sure either
next time we'll either talk about
cameras I mean besides yeah or we'll
talk about the actual transformation
matrix right and how to actually how to
actually tie transforms into primitives
that we render onto the screen because
the way that that kind of works is that
that transform actually needs to be
uploaded to the shader so in that sense
it needs like it needs to know what
shade are you're rendering with and to
do that properly requires a material
system but obviously there's a there's a
way for us to do it kind of quickly and
we'll probably do that so that we can
actually start having stuff on the
screen and that's been really exciting
because once we have that kind of stuff
we can just you know once we have a cat
good camera system and ways to kind of
submit like begin a scene with a certain
camera and submit objects with different
transforms we can actually start
building up the same there's the main
building blocks we need and then from
there you know we can start rendering an
actual 3d scene which is ultimately
where we're kind of staring towards but
you know there's other stuff we can do
along the way like textures because
that's kind of a 2d thing anyway so we
can you know we're drawing a rectangle
right now why not texture it right so
we'll have to deal with that at some
point and then there's other things that
I don't really want to do now but we I
mean we should but it just closed us
down it's very complicated but basically
that kind of render command Q and
multi-threading our renderer that stuff
will probably do in the future once we
actually have a 3d scene to play around
with because that's more of an
optimization that's no way gonna be a
bottleneck at this point and it's just
gonna further complicate our code so I'd
rather kind of do the other stuff first
anyway I know what you guys think and I
will see you next time goodbye
you
[Music]